for a younger generation under the
tongue i know it is that [ __ ]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by colin farrell
he's a golden globe award-winning actor
with a number of eagerly awaited
projects on the way including his role
as the penguin and the batman coming to
theaters on march 4th a role he'll then
reprise in an hbo max series that delves
into the penguin's rise to power so be
on the lookout for that and he also
stars in the coconut directed science
fiction drama after yang which is
likewise set to release on march 4th
colin farrell welcome to the show thanks
for having me sean i am already in
trouble a little bit i'm trying to
figure out which ones i i did a little
tap on it and i think and i didn't know
they were
already spiking i'm already now do we
only do a dab at the end yeah only a dab
at the end i like how you have some
insight here yeah because my son was
very excited my youngest boy henry is
very excited about me coming on so we
watched a couple episodes i've actually
never had uh so many people excited
about me doing a show ever when i say so
many i mean three but i have a very
tight group of not many friends and yeah
my brother-in-law
and one of my best friends mark and his
son charlie and my boy henry are so
excited about me coming on here and i
never had anyone in my life saying oh my
god you're going on jay leno or any of
those so here we are well are you ready
to put on a show come on man i know i
can't fail how does one fail
all right bon appetit bon appetit
it's also breakfast so it's a bit weird
just before the heat starts it's just a
bit nasty already
so your new film after yang is a sci-fi
film that bucks many of the genres
conventions from its focus on the
natural world instead of a futuristic
metropolis and then even the technology
which is really more of a background
character
koganata is such a distinctive
filmmaking style and aesthetic thinking
back to your time on set what would you
say makes him distinct as a director i
was told never to speak with my mouth
full but that would be bad television
so we'll continue to talk um
he is a really beautiful man coconut
honest god he's that loveliest
kindest most gentle man did you see the
film yes i did i saw the film some of it
so there's a there's a kind of a
peacefulness and a meditative aspect to
the film um
and cognitive feels like that is a man
he's incredibly zen and has a mad depth
to him
again it's not loud there's no action
there's no massive emotional outburst in
the film it's all very common but the
questions that
it asks the areas in which it's curious
in relation to the human condition for
me were fascinating when i read it i
just loved it but it wasn't a page
turner which sounds bad it's like oh it
wasn't a page there so you weren't that
interested no i really was but it was a
slow read because as i was reading i was
very affected by it more than i am most
the time in reading scripts you know so
and his aesthetic coconutty i think it
was his great grandfather was an
incredibly renowned artist in
calligraphy which made perfect sense
when he told me that kind of like of
course is your understanding of space
and your understanding of geometry and
architecture and you know all made sense
so i i had such a such a joy to work
with them
[Music]
what's this one dawson's
is the spice only on the top or do i
have to eat the whole thing i know that
i don't have to do anything i get it but
you know what i mean i'm in for a penny
for a pound right well
there is full coverage on the wings so
there's no way that you can duck it oh
that's important
i did what i did earlier on did me a
favor because i
messed myself up by having a dip of a
later one yeah so the first one i didn't
even notice wow that's a lot of meat
obviously trailblazing a hot one
strategy over here yeah accidentally
some of the best things i've done in my
life in accidents no intention on my
part
so i'm interested in that fundamental
part of being an actor which is deciding
what projects you're interested in based
on what's on the page
what is the actual process of reading
scripts like for you like how is it
different if at all from reading for
pleasure um it's a nice question um
sometimes a script can be really good
and you can feel really strongly about
it and and and it could be really i did
a thing called the north water on
television and it was
so thanks man it was so dark and it was
so heavy and it was so grotesque and it
it really was concerned with the darker
recesses of the of the human experience
and the human mind
and the ugliness that we're capable of
which is
visible everywhere we go of course but
this was condensed into five hours of
really heightened drama and reading it
was it was a task but it was still
brilliant it was still really enjoyable
i was still gripped by it and sometimes
you read scripts and and you don't
connect and you
in any way and but sometimes you need
money and you go and do them anyway
that's happened a couple of times you
know and even then i'm very grateful to
be like the majority of people in the
world i would imagine or a lot of people
don't have a job that they feel
connected to so even if you know when
you hit that thing where people say you
know
in hollywood if they do a money job
and then one that they're more
passionate about they go one for them
and one for me it's like really you got
five million doing one for them so
generous one for them one for me it's
all for me
but sometimes i get spoiled where i
really feel connected to the material it
means a lot to me
i get to bring my uncertainty as a
parent to my uncertainty as a partner in
the past i'm single now my uncertainty
as a friend as a human being i get to
bring that to work a little bit not as
therapy per se but it does
come onto the dance floor and i get to
ask certain questions that i've already
been asking myself just as a man you
know
[Music]
calabria calabrian chilis all the way
from italy mm-hmm
oh [ __ ] do you build up a tolerance have
you built up a tolerance over the years
you have are just a familiarity with the
pain that allows you to experience it in
a way that doesn't totally freak you out
the way that you said that the
familiarity with the pain i think is the
most important thing because i know what
to expect you know like life yeah
exactly what do i get i just i get this
familiarity with the pain of being human
so a lot of times though the guest
though it'll be the spiciest thing that
they've ever eaten in their lives and
then they're doing it in this bizarre
context you know what i mean sometimes i
just try to be like a support system and
not focus on my own pain if that makes
sense yeah yeah i respect that man
so i understand that despite being
roughly the size of maine ireland has
many different accents and dialects so
much so in fact that you probably notice
the difference just driving 10 miles
from village to village yep of all the
dialects that you've had to master for
various movie roles over the years which
was the most tedious or most time
consuming to learn i honest to god i
i've tried a couple of times to do um i
don't know what you would call it
standard american
when someone says standard american
accent and i find that the trickiest
um because generalities don't really
help you as an actor do you know what i
mean
the more specific you can be of course
yeah and then within the specificity
that you've found yourself
aligned with
then there's room for play of course you
should always be free to do this that
and the other it's not about
but but if just a general american
accent it just sounds general it sounds
vague and it almost sounds insulting it
sounds like you're not respecting
the character or the project or the
script you know that you really should
get very specific so all the really good
dialect coaches they're as
sociologically interested as they are in
sounds they really give you a whole
context for the world in which this
character grew up and how they feel
about certain things and the political
or you know economic climate of the area
they grew up in so that's when it gets
really interesting and that's when it
gets really specific but generalized
american i would be like oh i just feel
vanilla
but that's me i can't blame general
americans whatever they are
angry goat phoenix like a hybrid
oh it's got a little tang to it didn't
it yeah
it's the first one that went off the
reservation and decided to bring in a
little fruit
broad
it goes across the mouth it doesn't just
hit one spot
full coverage just
absolutely ambient
so when we had tom holland on the show
he talked about how playing a superhero
can sometimes take away your biggest
strength as an actor since your face is
always hidden behind a mask but that it
allows for more physicality in the
performance and i'm wondering if a
corollary can be made for prosthetics or
even a mike marino designed fat suit
like how does playing the penguin in a
costume in which you look unrecognizable
how does that shape or inform a
performance
for me it was absolute liberation
look being covered i thought oh careful
oh yeah
amateur mistake oh man thank god i
wasn't eating with my knuckles
um
i thought that it would be
very um
limiting i really did i thought i'd be
very just oppressed by having this holy
and it was totally the opposite
when the piece moves as well as the
piece that was designed for the penguin
moved my eyebrows moved to my cheeks and
my smile it was [ __ ] insane i didn't
have any fear that colin could be seen
through like some days you wake up as an
actor and you're having a [ __ ] day man
you know you've had like people do
you've had bad dreams something's not
going right in your personal life and
you're going to work and you pretend to
be someone else and that could sound
like a relief oh but you're having a
[ __ ] time as yourself so cool you get a
few hours to be someone else not really
you can't not bring yourself to the
party you're always there so there was
something about there was a buffer
between me and my fellow actors with
this mask on that just liberated me like
i'd never been liberated before so it
was the complete opposite of what i
thought
it was it was so much fun so much fun
and it was three or four hours
and it was four hours to start in the
chair and then they got it down to about
two hours um it was worth every minute
is it true that the climactic concert
scene and crazy heart that you guys only
had 10 minutes to shoot that because it
happened in the middle of a toby keith
concert
yeah man i thought i was going to get
bottled
i thought it was a [ __ ] dead man
because i think
i don't know i'd had a few films anyway
that didn't work and i played a couple
of characters whose sexuality was in
question and you know anyway just look
toby keith concert and there were
bunches crowd having a good time and
they were well into evening and the
beers had been
um were on board and uh
i know if i was at a
if i was a fan of toby keane i was at a
toby key concert i was half cut and then
somebody come on said we're going to
just stop the evening now because a
bunch of actors want to come on and do a
little make-believe i'd be like [ __ ] you
so i really kind of wanted a shield out
there in front of me but everyone was
cool that was just my face everyone was
awesome and now they had a crane at the
back of the stadium and then they had a
steady cam coming on the stage to get
the closer stuff and it was well
orchestrated they've been there all
afternoon so we just went on and as you
do bluffed yeah it was cool it's fun is
it true that while filming the recruit
al pacino actually damaged the car that
you guys are driving around in and then
the damage is actually visible in the
film when you guys roll up to the saigon
pagoda i love i have no idea but i will
research that later on driver side back
door big white street diddy big white i
remember
yeah i might remember all of that
project but
i'll research it probably sounds echoes
of familiar
is it true that steven spielberg hired
the 12 best contortionists in the world
to do that futuristic yoga scene and
minority report oh yeah i heard that
yeah the 12 best contortions in the
world imagine being number 13.
that [ __ ] suck wasn't am i like oh
yeah well they said it was unlucky for
some i guess
yeah i don't know i know there was a
bunch of people that were able to do mad
things with their bodies that day but i
wasn't working is it true that the open
heart surgery scenes and the killing of
a sacred deer are very real and that you
actually attended a quadruple bypass in
person real real
real real real real doesn't get any more
real smelling burning flesh
yeah it was intense
very intense
i [ __ ] never saw anything like it in
my life sean
so upsetting as horrible as it looked i
i had an appreciation for the checks and
balances of the human body i did i came
away from it going okay it really is
what we've all known but i've seen it in
action when it's been broken down and
somebody's trying to fix it it is put up
and it's in a garage and it's a car it's
an engine it's a computer it's whatever
there are certain things that have
certain consequences and you plug
certain things in certain somewhere
obviously it's gross simplification but
i came away from it going yeah it was
weird i wouldn't want to see it again
wow yeah on that note
that's not are you ready to move on to
the next wing yeah all right so this one
queen majesty coco ghost coco ghost i'm
expecting obviously a little hint of
chocolate at least i will be very
disappointed in writing a letter to
queen majesty which my people have sure
done many times over the years it's not
her is it
[Music]
they try to make all the labels really
more threatening
[Laughter]
like those energy drinks that look like
they're hugging plutonium in a [ __ ]
con
you know those ones
crushing it
crushing it
so i'm working in the new world with
legendary director terence malik he told
this amazing anecdote about how an actor
was delivering their lines and uh
terence would hear a bird off camera and
then pan over to the bird while the
actor was missing dialogue can you
expand on what you meant by the
beautiful contradiction of his obsessive
planning and freeform sensibility i
remember one time there was a rainstorm
and we were shooting in west virginia
sheet lightning coming down and then
forks loud loud claps of thunder
deafening and
then i heard when the jews go oh jesus
oh christ will somebody go and get terry
and we looked out and his [ __ ] dude
terry
malik
has a conductor he's a camera which is a
[ __ ] conductor basically on his
shoulder and he's out in the f and the
grass is blowing and he's in the middle
of a [ __ ] lightning storm it was the
most beautiful thing ever and he's not
stupid he's very bright very wise man
but he just
is so enamored with and so fascinated by
nature which is why sometimes human
beings aren't really the central aspect
in his film extraordinary fellow but he
did i mean and every actor that's worked
with them if they work closely with them
have a story of his of them being
mid-sentence you know thinking they're
[ __ ] breaking new
ground in authenticity and i'd never
forget it i never forget i was i was
cory uncle was it was there and i was
uh i had a couple of lines i had to say
and as i was saying i'll never forget oh
is that an osprey
i know i feel [ __ ] and i found myself
somewhere between insulted and so
enamored
with his honesty and his sense of
presence you know gorgeous man
[Music]
13 angry scorpions it makes sense
even the colour of it
oh yeah already has kind of a sweetness
up front already
there's a threat in that sweetness
though
[Music]
what was to tell me about there was a
ghost pepper that time with chili
flowers chili claus yeah the ghost
pepper you had we ate a carolina reaper
is that the hottest
it was the guinness book of world
records hottest pepper in the world and
just ate that pod straight up so what
was that like what was that ghostbusters
it was like giving yourself a food
poisoning yeah
yeah violence like the cramps uh just
the the cold sweats you know you go from
like being overly overly hot your body
is just screaming
yeah yeah yeah exactly so regulate
regulate you go there you go it doesn't
know what to do your whole equilibrium
is scrambled like i would
the only way i'd ever do that again
is if chile klaus who i cannot say no to
approached me and was just like we gotta
do it we gotta do a part three that's
the only reason i'd do it was it the
once you did us together we actually did
it twice we did it on two different
occasions
brutal yeah we and you were sick for a
few hours afterwards at that night yeah
five or six hours yeah i'm just like
holding a jug of milk in my living room
and just filling my mouth up with the
milk and just keeping it in my mouth and
just spitting
i'm feeling that [ __ ] you mustn't
have wiped your ass in years man you
must be like the king of the dab exactly
just clean clean oh my god stab just a
little dabble do you that's brutal yeah
it looked like it was very painful and
he just loves it doesn't he he just
finds meaning in that pain yeah
[Music]
so lovely such a lovely way about him
all right let's do it it is that time
it's a bomb
beyond insanity sean why would we go
beyond insanity on a tuesday morning at
11 48 or
afternoon at 12 53 or whatever it is i
know okay for entertaining that's comedy
all right let's see what this has got
yeah there's [ __ ] tons of it has a
lot to say yeah doesn't it
it's chatty
this one
never gets any easier
[Laughter]
it really is um
as advertised no but it's good to see
you suffer
misery loves company it really it does
help
i'm happy i could be that support system
for you
do you know what's the most insulting
one is under the tongue you know that
bit of
the guitar string under your tongue yeah
that [ __ ] hurts like it is now
bollocks i didn't think it would get me
that much
oh [ __ ] this is going to last a while
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh yeah you can't wipe your
tears yeah
of your autobiography
can't wipe the tears
i'm stealing that from
don't steal it i give it to you
i like [ __ ] inhales
[Music]
yeah okay
yeah i'm good thank you
for a younger generation under the
tongue i know it is that [ __ ]
for a younger generation that might
block at the idea of watching a black
and white movie from before their time
what makes the 1959 classic some like it
hot i love it so much a timeless film
that you never get sick of re-watching
um no i was going to say marilyn monroe
and that's true
in some sense
but
[ __ ] this
got me
the comedy is ageless the film is just a
beautiful word to a habit and marilyn
monroe would look for me
it was the first time i fell in love
you know in the first time i experienced
romantic love
i think i'm seven or eight
and already i wanted to rescue
marilyn i could make her happy he's
looking at lollipop i can make her happy
but um yeah i just
it's a perfect film this is it's a
perfect film this is a perfect romp
it's perfectly entertaining
some of the comedy in it is i mean jack
lemmon thinking that he's going to marry
the guy
you know
at least once a year
beginning to come back to [ __ ] planet
me too me too
really intense like a blackout almost
same and now i have like kind of a
lightheadedness going on
i can see your aura um it's otherworldly
but with that in mind
god damn
okay yeah sure man this one
this next one
is the pucker butt
mean green
the pucker butt
okay
hold on dead
the pucker butt
extreme
heat
but i think after the last one
it's almost a walk in the park oh yeah
the last one just card's a bomb it just
carpet bombs your whole being
ah
worst thing that one does the last poker
boat is just activates the [ __ ]
reactivates
the cumulative effect of the hot ones
gauntlet over here
yeah what are we doing this is great
though so ridiculous
that's so ridiculous
yeah
it's so stupid
not you know what i mean
no i'd take no offense yeah no offense i
understand
100 i mean i do for a living
so when daniel day lewis won the award
for best actor for his performance in
my left foot he said in his excitement
speech amazing that the voters had given
him the makings of one hell of a night
out in dublin yeah
is there a film of yours that you think
is most likely to earn you a free meal
from a stranger at an irish pub
at an irish pub uh at an irish pub in
los angeles it would be swat
yeah
yeah funny one but um in dublin maybe in
bruges that seems to people seem to like
that one that'd be a lot of what i'd
hear
at home if i ever heard anything good
from home i'm joking
my people have always been lovely with
me uh
i think i'm bruce is the one i'd hear
most through the years all right colin
farrell
sean
sean what's your surname evans shawn
evans yeah gosh so where are you
yeah yeah where's your family from uh
ireland but you know i've never i've
never traced it all the way back you
haven't dying to go to the country i'm
going to generate wrecks i'm going to
hit you up for the rest of these yeah
give me a number and there's a couple of
places i'd love you to go and see
i enjoy so much through the years when
people have said to me um
i'm going to ireland or we're going to
ireland is there a couple of places you
can recommend and just writing a few
things
on a send in a text it just
i get to go back for a second it's
lovely i enjoyed that so i'd enjoy that
very much yeah you love it and what a
profound thing it must be to have irish
heritage and em and go back there and
retrace your roots exactly it must be
this summer i'm trying i'm trying cool
oh this is the last the last dab oh so
this is you guys is this ah jesus
there it is you have your own course you
do he'd be a full nut
and we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to
okay
the last stop
the last tab if you have if you ever
open a pub you know what to call that as
well
what do i call it the last tab the last
app yeah
okay
is that it that's it you did it okay man
cheers cheers brother it's been a
pleasure
[Music]
all right colin farrell at long last
we've conquered the wings of death and
just one more hurdle bring this thing
full circle i've read that the seeds of
your acting career there are planted
when you saw henry thomas's performance
and e.t the extraterrestrial a
performance that moved you to tears and
inspired you to pursue a career in
acting
can you describe in as much detail as
possible under these very bizarre
circumstances what is it that you find
on the whole remarkable about e.t the
extraterrestrial what i thought was
remarkable first when i saw it was e.t
you know and and the excitement of that
and the
creature coming from a distant plane and
i would still find that remarkable about
it and but what i find more remarkable
now is
what a story it is about a broken family
you know like close encounters the third
kind i mean spielberg has made some of
the most as far as i'm concerned
entertaining films in the history of
cinema
but even when they're really
entertaining at their core there is some
kind of emotional psychological fracture
going on and the family in e.t is in
trouble and the feds walking through the
forest and it's always the keys rattling
those keys haunted me anytime i heard
keys rattling as a kid i was haunted and
magic
and when when when they take off
for the first time through that forest
and they start flying
i got goosebumps i got teary eyed on the
couch this christmas but that's me my
mortality and stuff i'm sure of it
[ __ ] you know nostalgia and
melancholy yeah but so many reasons why
it's a great film a beautiful and
eloquent love letter to e.t the
extraterrestrial and look at you colin
farrell taking on the wings of death
what's next very impressively
gauntlet down for the count now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let people know what you
have going on in your life what i have
going on in my life oh god where do we
start
uh career or personal
i've got going on i'm an actor i'm look
gainfully employed and
there's a couple of things coming out in
a few weeks one called the batman and
then another called and the batman
you'll probably hear about and see loads
of trailers and posters and stuff but
the one that really needs a bit of help
is called after yang and it's a small
independent film
with a lot of heart i think
anyway that's what i got going on and
then nothing else i'm unemployed now if
anyone out there has any scripts or any
actors come around
god bless y'all
thanks man
it's such a thrill and it's a pleasure
my favorite part of my job is diving in
the material and watching movies
great questions oh thank you [ __ ]
honestly the best questions i've i can
recall being asked
i think ever like because i was trying
to think of charlie rose no he didn't
really give a [ __ ] who i was what we do
charlie rose johnny rose is talking
about isabella martin mcdonough and
charlie rose looked at me or something
he went you did this uh film uh miami
i think he's in miami whatever miami
something he didn't even [ __ ] he
couldn't even get he couldn't even get
the second word of a two-word title of
an easy show that was really iconic
this one's for chilly clouds
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience in one convenient package i'm
proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
hot ones boneless chicken bites it's a
party in a bag and everyone's invited
[Music]